ذكرت صحيفه الواشنطن بوست ان الشخص الذي
سرب وثائق سريه امريكيه ادت الى تحقيق
يتعلق بالامن القومي هو شاب في العشرينيات
من العمر مولع بالاسلحه الناريه وكان يعمل
في قاعده عسكريه وفق ما نقلت عن زملاء له
في المجموعه الدردشه على الانترنت
الصحيفه ان الشخص الذي لم تذكر هويته نشر
معلومات سريه في مجموعه على منصه المراسله
الفوريه ديسكورد تضم نحو 20 رجلا وفتى
يجمعهما وصفته بالحب المشترك للاسلحه
والاعتادر العسكري والله ونقلت الصحيفه عن
زملاء له في مجموعه الدردشه انه اخبرهم
انه كان في منشاه عسكريه امنه تحضر
الهواتف المحموله والاجهزه الالكترونيه
الاخرى وقال انه قضى ساعات في نسخ بعض
المستندات السريه يدويا
واضافت واشنطن بوست ان المسرب بدا باعطاء
زملائه في مجموعه الدردشه قدرا صغيرا من
الاسرار ثم عندما ثبت ان تحويل مئات
الملفات السريه يدويا كان مرهقا للغايه
بدا بنشر مئات الصور للوثائق نفسها